congratulations season 5 yeah thank you
to make season 5 yeah it's all done is
it all done it was shot season 5 was
finished yet I'll cut together and ready
it is be watch yes I think they're still
doing post on 9 and 10
yeah they got a lot of don't worry they
don't by the time they show this it'll
be all ready is this gonna be known as
the warm and fuzzy season yes this is a
season where everyone I stopped
practicing law pajama parties yeah it's
a lot of we open a daycare center yep
yep I'm the crossing guard what can you
tell us I mean I've seen one episode mmm
I think it's r8c more than us
first pump nate is our biggest yeah
because he's in Everwood just to say
that the story moves faster the plots
get everything gets bigger the violence
gets bigger the images the storytelling
is faster bigger louder more fun I think
season 5 pacing action plot all of it
just became very much there is one point
where the rifle fire is louder than
anything you've ever heard yeah I was
very excited yeah so it's a really fun
season watching it on a big screen TV
and turn the sound up yeah or do and get
the dog out of the room because they're
gonna jump I in the very first episode
your character has a little bit of a
moral dilemma yes and so Kim tough is
she gonna go to the dark side what's
going on I am in the dark I can't say
but I do think it was Laura she is the
she's nuts are they dark yes um Jimmy's
Luke Skywalker
and there's Yoda this is baby Yoda no I
think that they very much delve into
that question of what is making this
person tick and all of that control and
compartmentalizing that she does it
can't entirely come from we get some
deeply dark side of we do it's it's like
how genuinely like in your face like
what's going on with her than just being
a no it's like real maybe not a real
danger there okay okay so put forth some
like real danger vibes otherwise we get
along great but they don't like each
other and have no shared interests
during shooting but we asked him to move
in and he said no no gun to my head
please God let me get away from I'm
gonna go home wait you live together
Washington a couple of us yeah Bob Bob a
couple yeah try3
what about we live it stays there
sometimes Fadem lives there three the
place I'm camera guy from the the things
we don't grow the student clunker they
have student subgroups some of the
actors yet we all stay sharehouse three
does it help acting well you can
rehearse yeah it's actually came there
and we are lucky we are lucky enough
that we all rehearsal in ten minutes in
the kitchen but yes we do that cuz you
have to run the scripts are so dense and
so beautifully written and they are the
writing is the King to all of us and we
care deeply about making it sound it's
theirs it's such a compliment when
people ask us if we're improving on the
show and we're not we just drill our
lines and rehearse ad nauseam
so yeah it is kind of like don't be
careful going to the kitchen for coffee
because someone's gonna make you run
lines with me yeah though you when you
said the show is dense that is exactly
yeah I mean even when I watch them in
them and when I've got when they air and
I get to watch them as a fan I always
cannot believe that was only one hour
when is it done I always feel like it
feels like I just watched three hours of
storytelling somehow crammed in there
it's really incredible what they do I
want to ask plain dark characters just
it make you kinder in real life yeah I
wish it did you mean like exercising
those demons so that you can go forth
and be nicer hmm I kick the dog just for
I left the house just to let her know I
was there no I would think sometimes as
oh it must be harder tonight again I'm
gonna give you an example
Bobby Bobby just finished doing a whole
fight thing but he he got himself in
great shape for and he did and I said
how was it he said on a fighting was so
great it's because it gets it out so if
I can only speak for myself but I get to
play these characters and you know what
I'm a little more gentle in the world
because of it it's what just maybe if
you if you get to stand up and beat the
piss out of something you know you're
gonna feel better
I teach my little granddaughters as they
come year after year after year and
there's a great one this year on the
show I'd not been real life grand don't
teach him how to throw a punch and their
little 7 year olds with bird-like wrists
and stuff and they've never done it and
all of a sudden and they get into it
just the physicality of it yeah I know
we got a wrap up soon I want to
congratulate you want Little Women
Thanks yeah he's fun to be a part of it
picture or not and yeah nominations so
tell are you gonna be going to the
Oscars oh I don't know I suppose I'll go
to something a party or something no I
don't know about the thing itself but it
was your reaction when you heard the
news well I loved being a part of the
movie
women very very much everyone got along
great and we were good friends and we
got to shoot it in Concord right where
the story takes place and also I got to
play a sweet if a little scatterbrained
guy I'm just kind of the opposite of
Saul who's conniving and his brain is
not so scattered but it was nice to play
that kind of energy on screen